jean-marc cbs bonjour merci d'être avec
nous alors on le voit bien le scrutin
était marqué par un taux record
d'abstention
en cause la crise sanitaire ou pas
seulement mais tout est pas seulement je
crois que la montée des électeurs verts
n'a surpris personne
après les élections européennes après le
premier tour aussi des municipales et se
retrouvait en position de force quoi
qu'il ya là trois raisons à tous à un
trait pour simplifier la la forte
progression correspond un peu à l'air du
temps si j'ose dire mais c'est à l'air
du temps qui souffrent qui souffle
beaucoup dans toutes les démocraties
occidentales et notamment dans les
démocraties d'europe du nord avec la
conviction que ce phénomène et c'est
essentiellement dû aux risques que
présente le réchauffement climatique au
phénomène aussi que ce réchauffement
climatique est imputable à l'activité
humaine donc les écologistes disent bas
et côté si on veut on peut
on peut freiner le réchauffement
climatique la deuxième la deuxième
raison c'est que les mouvements
écologiques présente des outils
quotidiens pour résoudre les problèmes
et s'appelait ben quand même aux
électeurs le covoiturage le tri des
déchets l'isolation thermique
l'utilisation des vélos tout ça ça fait
mouche à peu donné dans les programmes
et puis la troisième raison c'est que
les mouvements écologiques ont profité
de l'effondrement des partis politiques
traditionnels qui avait pas de réponse
évidente à toutes ces questions c'est
ainsi qu'en france
les verts ont siphonné aux vêtements les
partis de gauche on voit dans les
résultats sont clairs aujourd'hui dans
la plupart des grandes piles la gauche a
disparu mais la droite aussi a en partie
disparu elle avait disparu avec
l'arrivée de deux heures marche et on
marche un fait les frais aussi de ces
deux difficultés écologie relance
économique services publics quelles sont
les demandes qui ressorte du résultat de
ces élections là la question maintenant
va être de savoir si les français
veulent vraiment que leur ville soit
administrée par les verts ça va être une
vraie question ça notamment dans les
grandes villes parce qu'ils n'ont pas
l'expérience de l'administration d'une
très grande ville
et puis qu'en plus les le taux
d'abstention est tel que il court le
risque de pas être soutenus par l'epa
par les populations alors les programmes
des écologistes de dix acteurs sont
assez séduisant puisqu'ils répondent à
des problèmes côte
y'a tout le monde est d'accord en france
pour que la qualité de l'air soient
bonnes que les transports publics
fonctionnent bien soit mieux organisé
que l'énergie soit moins cher que les
enfants à l'école mais les moyens à
utiliser pour faire tout ça sont rona on
a assez peu d'éléments là dessus pour
apprécier ce que peuvent faire les
écolos on sait par exemple que pendant
la crise sanitaire mais écologistes ont
fait un diagnostic en disant que c'était
sans doute le fait de la mondialisation
de la de l'exportation des échanges
internationaux tout ça bon mais on sait
aussi que les écologistes ont fait
campagne par exemple pour les médecines
naturelles contre les vaccins
donc ils sont assez discrets finalement
parce qu'il se rendu compte qu'on avait
sans doute besoin que les populations
avaient sans doute besoin d'autre chose
que le développement des méthodes de
médecine naturelle ya il faut un
programme et ce programme là c'est vrai
on le cherche actuellement on parle
beaucoup de cette percée inédite pour
les verts avec des métropoles très
symbolique comme lyon est ce que c'est
une montée qui avait déjà été amorcée à
votre année elle avait déjà été amorcée
joue au moment des élections européennes
elle avait été amorcée au moment du
premier tour des débuts du sipal et je
crois qu'il ya une vraie demande la
demande et les simples opinions a besoin
de sécurité sanitaire elle a besoin de
changement on est aussi dans le bain et
un v des macros le pille on a besoin
d'eux mais l'opinion a aussi besoin de
croissance économique elle a aussi
besoin d'emplois de création d'emplois
l'opinion a besoin que les avions
décollent
or les écologie sont plutôt partisan
d'un modèle de croissance
j'allais dire plus ralenti d'un modèle
de croissance plus économes en matière
d'énergie d'énergie voici les veulent
sans doute point de croissance
et quelque part moins d'activité une
stratégie de croissance faible ne permet
pas de payer le modèle de dépenses
sociales dont on a besoin ne permet pas
de payer les dépenses publiques dont on
a besoin le progrès scientifique est
important et ce progrès scientifiques ne
se paye que par la croissance économique
alors une fois arrivée au pouvoir les
écologistes vont se retrouver devant
leurs responsabilités
ils vont être obligés de changer leur
programme vraisemblablement
et de prendre finalement les choses en
main c'est ce qui s'est passé en
allemagne sur des vous les allemands les
verts allemands et bien ont beaucoup
évolué depuis leur arrivée et leur
alliance avec angela merkel à les
apports habituels angela merkel mais ça
fait déjà fait changer les a convaincus
par exemple que les centrales nucléaires
étaient sûrement plus propre et ce qui
était un évidence que les centrales à
charbon que les écologistes avaient fait
réouvrir pour fabriquer l'électricité
donc on s'aperçoit que les qualités
qu'il faut pour accéder au pouvoir ne
sont sans doute pas celle les qualités
et les programmes qu'ils photo exercer
ce pouvoir
on va voir les preuves la république
heures marche de son côté ne gagne
aucune grande ville et se fait abattre
dans des métropoles où ils sont pourtant
bien implantés comme lyon ou strasbourg
que signifie ce revers pour la majorité
présidentielle
écoutez c'est pas l'échec se lécher pour
emmanuel macro salle échec pour la
majorité présidentielle ça va sans doute
influencé la dernière partie du la
deuxième partie du quinquennat de des
menus et le maquereau et c'est
d'ailleurs pas par hasard s'il a
précipité son agenda et qu'il reçoit
notamment aujourd'hui les 120 français
qui avaient été tirés au sort pour
pouvoir établir un programme de
rénovation et un programme l'écologie on
va voir comment les choses se passent
mais ça va quand même été assez
compliqué de pour associer finalement
les mouvements écologie à l'action
gouvernementale
on a des leaders en écologie mais on
s'aperçoit avec l'expérience nicolas
hulot même ségolène royal on s'aperçoit
que la confrontation entre la position
gouvernementale et l'exercice de la
responsabilité gouvernementale est
difficilement compatible
jean-marc semestre merci d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes journaliste et éditorialiste et
cote à pic